bueno tal vez a estas alturas ya sepas o
tal vez no lo sepas que todas las rectas
se pueden ver de la forma y es igual a
mx más bien y decíamos que esta forma en
la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
porque m es la pendiente y recuerda que
la pendiente la definimos como el cambio
en y entre el cambio en x lo que cambia
verticalmente a comparación de lo que
cambio horizontalmente o el alza entre
el avance mientras que ve es la ordenada
el origen o en la intersección con el
eje de las 10 que por cierto habíamos
visto que ésta era la intersección con
el eje layers porque cuando x valía cero
es decir cuando movemos ni para la
derecha ni para la izquierda y entonces
por lo tanto nos mantenemos en el eje el
ayer pues que me va a quedar que es
igual a m por 0 más bien lo único que
siendo sustituyendo a x por 0 pero me
por 0 es 0 y se va entonces siempre
sencillamente me queda que es igual a
ver por lo tanto cuando x vale 0
vale b estamos en el punto cero b que si
te das cuenta es justo el punto de
intersección con el eje de la cra y de
igual manera podremos ponerle cualquier
otro valor a x para ver qué es lo que
pasaría con ésta
de vista como en forma general por
ejemplo si ponemos que x vale 1
cuánto vale ley m a ver déjame
escribirlo aquí si x vale en lugar de 0
le voy a poner el valor de 1 entonces
quién va a ser pues x es igual a 1 y ya
me va a quedar y es igual a m por uno
pero m por unos uno más ven entonces
tenemos otro nuevo punto el punto uno
coma
m bent y si te das cuenta si podemos
construir todos los puntos de nuestra
recta sustituyendo valores de x pero
bueno ahora que ya tenemos estos dos
puntos me gustaría ver cuál es la
pendiente entre estos dos puntos es
decir de dos menos de uno entre x 2 - x
1 el cambio en y entre el cambio en x y
vamos a tomarnos como punto final el
punto de amarillo es decir m b - b entre
1 - 0 la diferencia en las coordenadas
de y menos las diferencias en las
coordenadas de x ya cuánto va a ser
igual a esto pues que me va a quedar m
bmw pues éstas 12 cancelan y solamente
me queda m 10 pues es 1
entre 1 sm y pues si tiene toda la
lógica del mundo si habíamos dicho que
mi pendiente era m pues nos acabamos de
dar cuenta que llegamos a lo mismo por
lo tanto mi pendiente m es decir el
coeficiente que está lado de la x va a
ser muy pendiente y ve el coeficiente
libre va a ser mi intersección con el
eje de las 10 así que bueno aquí tenemos
tres rectas y lo que yo quiero saber es
la ecuación de este estilo de la forma
pendiente ordenada el origen de estas
tres rectas así que pues tenemos las
gráficas solamente y vamos a fijarnos en
la recta vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar su ecuación de esta forma a
qué sabemos de a pues lo primero que
quiero que veamos es cuál es su
pendiente así que mueve a tomar un punto
me voy a tomar este punto de aquí y voy
a ver cuánto cambio en x cuánto cambio
el día para llegar a otro punto fíjate
bien me voy a tomar este otro punto de
acá entonces si yo cambio todo esto en x
van a ser 123 cambios en x delta de x va
a ser igual a 3 ya cuánto cambian si
cambiamos delta de x igual a 3 y
cambiados hacia abajo es decir delta de
y es igual a menos
2 porque el cambio es hacia abajo como
mi recta es descendiente entonces la
pendiente tiene que ser negativa y la
pendiente el delta de y entre delta de x
que por cierto delta de x vale 3 delta
de lleva de menos 2 y entonces ya
sabemos que mi pendiente de esta recta
vale menos dos tercios el cambio entre
el cambio en x 3 unidades cambiamos a la
derecha mientras cambiamos dos unidades
hacia abajo y de igual manera no te
puedes tomar cualquier otro punto de
esta recta y si caminas una pendiente de
menos dos tercios entonces te vas a dar
cuenta que vas a llegar a otro punto de
esta recta muy bien ya tenemos la
pendiente ahora cuánto vale ven para
fijarnos en vez lo primero que quiero
que veamos es este punto de aquí pero
como encontramos este punto de aquí en
donde interceptamos el eje de las 10
pues bueno si nosotros empezamos en este
punto vamos a caminar una unidad hacia
la derecha y como muy pendientes de
menos dos tercios vamos a bajar menos
dos tercios de unidad es decir que este
punto de aquí es un entero un tercio
porque si hasta acá arriba eran dos
entonces dos menos dos tercios es
exactamente lo mismo que un entero un
tercio o cuatro tercios
y ya con esto es el valor de ver verbal
de cuatro tercios y por lo tanto tiempo
de escribir que es igual a mx es decir
menos dos tercios de x más ven pero vale
cuatro tercios y ya con esto tengo una
ecuación de la forma pendiente ordenada
al origen de esta recta a muy bien 1 -
así que vámonos al ejercicio b y es pero
que haya menos fracciones fíjate bien
voy a empezar en este punto lo primero
que voy a sacar es la pendiente así que
déjame poner aquí la recta en la recta b
ya que es cambio en x y esto va a ser
igual a arribas cambio en 10 entonces si
yo estoy aquí en xy no muevo 1 date
cuenta que el cambio en x delta de x es
1 mientras que el cambio en y es 33
hacia arriba por lo tanto el cambio en
que es positivo por cada una unidad que
yo me cambien x cambio tres unidades en
james de manera positiva por lo tanto
delta de x es 1 del 10 son 3 y 3 / 1
estrés perfecto ya tengo la pendiente y
ahora voy a buscar la ordenada al origen
que si te das cuenta este de aquí cuando
x vale 0 llévale uno entonces
vale 1 y ya tengo la pendiente ya tengo
la ordenada el origen me queda que james
es igual a mx es decir a 3x más b pero
vale 1 más 1
ahora vamos a fijarnos en la recta cm en
esta última recta de este plano
cartesiano y vamos a hacer lo mismo pero
date cuenta que lo primero que sabemos
es que nuestra ordenada el origen vale
menos dos cuando x vale cero entonces
lleva al menos dos por lo tanto vale
menos dos y cuánto vale la pendiente
pues vamos a fijarnos el cambio en y
entre el cambio en x y entonces yo estoy
aquí y me muevo en x
vamos a ver 1234 unidades en x delta de
xc igual a 4 porque ojo me estoy
moviendo a la derecha lleva a cambiar
todos en sentido positivo porque me
estoy moviendo hacia arriba entonces del
32 del de de x es 42 cuartos y cuántos
dos cuartos esto es lo mismo que un
medio por lo tanto ya sé la pendiente ya
se lo ordena el origen y es igual a un
medio de x menos 2 recuerda que lo único
que hay que hacer es sustituir los
valores de b
de la pendiente y bueno ahora vámonos al
sentido contrario
qué pasa si ahora tenemos la ecuación de
la recta aquí tenemos la pendiente aquí
la ordenada al origen como gráfico yo a
esta recta así que vamos a fijarnos en
la primera recta que tenemos aquí dice
que mi intersección con el eje de las 10
es igual a 5 es decir b vale 5 b vale 5
hasta 234 aquí está 5 en este punto
estamos en un principio y después no es
una pendiente de 2 recuerda que todos lo
podemos ver como 2 sobre 1 por lo tanto
por cada cambio en x vamos a cambiar 2
en 10 positivamente 1 y 2 para arriba
después 1 a la derecha y 2 para arriba y
de igual manera el sentido contrario si
yo cambio 1 la izquierda van a ser 2
para abajo 1 a la izquierda dos para
abajo y así nos podríamos seguir toda la
vida pero bueno aquí ya se ve claramente
que esta es mi línea recta esta que
estoy dibujando aquí va a bajar va a
subir y esta línea recta no me queda
nada
perfecto ya tengo mi primer ejercicio de
esta línea recta ya que agarre confianza
pues voy a hacer ahora el segundo
ejercicio y es igual a menos 0.2 x + 7
déjame escribirlo aquí y es igual a
menos punto 2 x + 7 y aquí la clave es
escribir este menos 0.2 x este menos 0.2
como un quebrado menos 0.2 es lo mismo
que menos un quinto menos un quinto de x
7 porque aquí ya tengo la ordenada el
origen la ordenada el origen es 7 aquí
vamos 567 estamos situados por ende en
este punto de aquí y después fíjate la
pendiente dice que por cada cinco
cambios en x vamos a cambiar menos un
cambio en jr es decir por cada 5 cambios
de manera horizontal hacia la derecha
vamos a hacer un cambio hacia abajo del
tdi entre delta de x así que vamos a
hacerlo uno dos tres cuatro cinco
cambios a la derecha y un cambio del 10
hacia abajo y vamos a ir otra vez 1 2 3
4 5 cambios a la derecha un cambio hacia
abajo y el sentido contrario sólo hay
que invertir las cosas
porque date cuenta que menos un quinto
es exactamente lo mismo que escribir uno
entre menos cinco eso quiere decir que
por cada cinco cambios hacia la
izquierda vamos a hacer un cambio hacia
arriba uno dos tres cuatro cinco y un
cambio hacia arriba ahora otra vez uno
dos tres cuatro cinco y un cambio hacia
arriba y perfecto ya tengo bastantes
puntos de esta recta y la voy a trazar
más o menos así o al menos espero que se
entienda la idea así que pues mejor
vamos a hacer la siguiente gráfica de la
siguiente ecuación y es igual a menos x
y lo primero que quiero que te des
cuenta es que aquí no tenemos ordenada
el origen esto es lo mismo que escribir
10 igual a mx + veto en de b vale 0 y m
vale menos 1
aquí estamos sumando 0 y por lo tanto me
ordenada el origen es 0 o dicho de otra
manera pasamos por el punto 0 0 por el
origen de este plano canciano y después
dice que tenemos una pendiente de menos
1 - x es exactamente lo mismo que menos
1 y dicho de otra manera por cada cambio
de la derecha vamos a bajar 1
entonces 11 después 11 hacia abajo uno a
la derecha uno hacia abajo y de igual
manera de sentido contrario uno a la
izquierda uno hacia arriba uno a la
izquierda uno se arriba y bueno creo que
más o menos vas viendo cómo va el patrón
de esta recta que voy a dibujar más o
menos por aquí y se acabó ya tenemos
otra recta más así que vamos a fijarnos
para finalizar en la última recta que
dice que es igual a 3.75 3.75 y si te
das cuenta que no tenemos nada de equis
todas las rectas sirven de la forma y es
igual a mx más b pero aquí no tenemos
nada de equis por lo tanto esto quiere
decir que esta misma recta la podemos
escribir de la forma y es igual a 0 x +
3.75 0 x x se van t solamente me queda
3.75 o dicho de otra manera tenemos una
pendiente de 0 el cambio con respecto a
x es de 0 fíjate bien no importa cuánto
cambia a la derecha o la izquierda y
cambia 0 o sea no cambia por más que me
mueva a la izquierda oa la derecha ya no
va a subir ni bajar así que si yo estoy
aquí en el punto cero
75 pues no voy a mantener en 3.75 si yo
cambio 1 en x me voy a mantener en 3.75
o si cambio 20 en x no voy a mantener en
3.75 y entonces la recta se ve así así
que aquí tenemos a una recta constante
oa una recta horizontal espero que hayas
encontrado bastante interesante